é bom pessoal muito tem se discutido
sobre a universidade do futuro né
e eu acho que existe um senso é comum
que é favorável a essa faculdade do
futuro porque se a gente for para para
pensarmos assim anos atrás as coisas
eram totalmente diferentes do que são
hoje as relações como a gente é se movia
enfim mas se a gente olhar a sala de
aula
ela era assim anos atrás e hoje ela
continua da mesma forma pode ter mudado
a foto era preto e branco agora ter uma
resolução melhor é colorida mas é
basicamente a mesma coisa e que o ponto
é que eu estou sendo universitário
agora hoje e eu vou ter uma formação que
não está de acordo com as demandas dessa
nossa nova realidade porque a minha
universidade do passada o melhor é como
eu posso ter a melhor formação
universitária é possível com o que eu
tenho em mãos agora e essa foi uma
pergunta que eu venho me fazendo eu sou
estudante
aqui dá da j universitário e é uma
pergunta bastante difícil de responder
mas eu acho que eu tenho algumas algumas
com visões a conclusões e que podem
servir como dicas que eu gostaria de
compartilhar aqui então vamos pensar
sobre o universitário do futuro em vez
da universidade de altura e pra começar
vale a pena a gente entender como esse
modelo educacional que a gente tem
atualmente é nasceu e isso tem muito a
ver com o período em que ele foi
estabelecida que foi um período marcado
pelo projectista pelo modo de produção
é que priorizavam a escala vem
chacoalhando idade é que priorizavam a a
a uniformidade preencher personalização
por meio de linhas de produção e e faz
bastante sentido se a gente for para
pensar porque nessa época conhecimento é
um bem extremamente em escasso
conhecimento não era acessível também
poucos lugares e um desses lugares é
justamente a universidade então o papel
da universidade é disseminar ad maneira
fica lado esse conhecimento ainda que
fosse de de forma superficial pra levar
aquele que conseguia o seu canudo de
papel para o mercado de trabalho se
escolhesse esse caminho ou pra academia
se quisesse de fato se aprofundar e
produzir conhecimento
então se eu for e colocar no nesse
modelo de educação eu como estudante de
relações internacionais entrou na
faculdade e jogam numa sala de aula para
cursar relações internacionais 1 ea
primeira matéria e eu curso relações
internacionais 1 2 3 e 4 no primeiro
período e assim que eu alcançar a
matéria elas internacionais 35 eu tenho
direito a um papel que fala que eu sou
graduada e enfim o problema é que isso
deixa de funcionar quando o conhecimento
deixa de ser escassa conhecimento passa
a ser abundante
se antes era o metal precioso como agora
é uma commodity a gente tem acesso que
separa a gente de praticamente todo o
conhecimento que o homem produziu e mexe
é uma pesquisa no google e não fala
informação não é saber qual que é a
altura do everest ou enfim é de artigos
de acesso a aulas livres e ainda que
exija uma curva de aprendizado tá lá
e também tem uma segunda é um segundo
ponto extremamente importante e que muda
desde que foi formada aquele nosso
modelo educacional ultrapassada que é a
capacidade de realização que deixou de
ser extremamente onerosa e complexa e
hoje é mais acessível e realização quer
dizer realmente fazer coisas então por
exemplo como era produzir um protótipo
de qualquer coisa há 100 anos atrás
quando nasceu aquele modelo é de
formação de de linha era praticamente
impossível tinha aqui é lugar 11
laboratórios e tinha que ficar um tempo
correndo atrás mas hoje a gente consegue
fazer um protótipo real com uma
impressora 3d é pessoal ou o que era
vender alguma coisa não sei por que você
queira vender algo há um tempo atrás
você teria que abrir uma loja física
campo burocracia danada hoje você pode
montar um e commerce em duas horas o
bebê pela página no facebook pode
mobilizar pessoas em torno de uma causa
através das redes sociais pode divulgar
sua música sem precisar de uma gravadora
propagar o cara da rádio pra tocar o som
enfim a mágica acontece quando a gente
soma abundância conhecimento abundante e
maior capacidade é realização e isso
tanto para a faculdade mas também para o
universitário universitário agora tem o
privilégio de conseguir ter experiências
que está em um ambiente que é propenso a
essas experiências novas e isso é
fantástico e também comecei a perceber
que alguns universitários perceberam que
podiam usar isso a seu favor e começaram
a ter uma
a achar o seu propósito é fazer algo que
fazia sentido que os movia e era muito
interessante que sempre com essa
formação pautada em experiências e não
pautada naquela linha de produção eles
estavam atrás de experiências relevantes
para cima e algo em comum entre eles era
achar o interesse dentro da da
universidade
e aí para xe pra algum tipo de
realização da realização que no início
em quase todos os casos é um pouco
difícil tem problemas mas quem consegue
superar esses problemas
a melhora se desenvolve evolui busca
novos interesses
fica bom naquilo que faz e acha de fato
é o seu propósito além de produzir algo
relevante e eu como não sou egoísta ou
dividir algumas histórias de de alguns
universitários que optaram por essa
formação orientada a experiência do
primeiro paulo que foi aluna tida do do
ct da ufrj de engenharia e ele percebeu
ele mesmo teve dificuldade em passar
pelo ciclo básico percebeu que outros
colegas também tinham que isso era um
baita de um problema alunos com
potencial mas acabavam repetindo sempre
matérias e ele resolveu desenvolver um
método próprio para ajudar esses
incidentes
ele conseguiu depois de errar um pouco
de melhorar o seu produto conseguiu
chegar no método extremamente eficiente
que hoje a maioria da dos alunos desses
cursos
usam pra passar nestas matérias isso deu
origem a essa empresa responde aí que
hoje é uma startup uma das principais de
estado da educação no brasil
ou também o ruben é esse que é graduanda
de comunicação aqui da ufrj que numa
matéria que precisava fazer um curta
usou máximo aquilo que a universidade
ofereceu contatos e produção pesquisa
é força de trabalho de seus colegas para
produzir algo que ele considerava de da
melhor qualidade e isso levou que aquele
é aquele trabalho de escola chegasse à
seleção oficial de cannes
o que é incrível ou também o lucas que é
estudante de engenharia que tinha um tio
com um problema motor e precisava de uma
prótese que custava cerca de 20 mil
dólares e não tinha condição de pagar
ele com a ajuda de professores
desenvolveu uma prótese bem mais barata
mais escalável e que solucionar essa dor
e hoje é algo economicamente viável é
outros exemplos também do joão
o joão que sempre gostou de jornalismo
jornalismo aprofundado diferente e por
isso começou uma revista digital é que
que a produzir conteúdo da maneira que
ele achava que fazer sentida e graças a
essa sua revista ele chegou é no
trabalho dos sonhos um estágio na
revista que mais admirava no piauí
hoje juliana de são paulo que tinha
alguns problemas na comunidade que vivia
e conseguiu
é é com a ajuda do de colegas
universitários com a ajuda de
professores criar uma ong que ajuda as
pessoas da sua comunidade ou até o usaa
lan que sempre gostou de administração
de empresas e cursa engenharia no ime e
lá ele teve um resultado sensacional na
empresa júnior conseguiu achar o que
gostava de fato e atualmente tanto maior
banco de investimento do país fazendo
algo que gosta nem um trabalho relevante
então aquela pergunta do começo como a
gente pode extrair o máximo da
universidade é uma pergunta difícil de
responder que acho que
eu não tenho capacidade de responder
ainda a gente pode perceber que nesses
casos os estudantes tiraram o melhor da
universidade conseguiram extrair o
máximo
acharam algo que fazia sentido pra eles
e começaram a produzir coisas relevantes
e isso porque eles usaram é essas novas
ferramentas que estão disponíveis pela
nossa geração ao invés de esperar que a
universidade é dessa formação pra eles e
essa é a mensagem que eu quero deixar se
a universidade é uma orelha uma
organização extremamente grande
burocrática avesso a mudanças seculares
o estudante universitário é um indivíduo
e indivíduo ele pode um mudar
simplesmente com a sua vontade e pelo
que me parece
quando essa vontade é de fazer é de
realizar experiências
ele alcança resultados legais rápido e e
com bastante eficácia
então esse é o convite que eu quero
fazer pra vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]